more resources will soon roll out to
help improve housing stability here in
Clark County it's called the eviction
diversion initiative and it could help
you for a Las Vegas family well this
program means hope
it is stressful right now I'm depressed
in 10 seconds
Alice and Manuel Ramirez have lived in
southern Nevada for more than 15 years
they say paying rent is becoming a
challenge we are only paying 8.75. now
we went up to 1100 then I found out
again that on December they're gonna
increase it
uh just two months today we're here
making a significant announcement they
were among the public inside the state
building in Downtown Las Vegas seeking
information about the additional
resources from the eviction diversion
initiative thanks to a 1.25 million
dollar Grant from the national Center of
state courts this program even does more
is the funds will help create a program
to identify Solutions and connect people
with resources services and housing
assistance chief judge Melissa Saragosa
says tenants who receive an eviction
notice should file an opposition by way
of an affidavit they will get an order
from the court directing them to appear
to the eviction diversion program
according to help of Southern Nevada
they estimate about 5 000 individuals
are unhoused every day they say our
current rental resources are not enough
which is forcing this family to seek
help I know there's folks they're The
Mooring helped in us but we could use
the help we could use a help and I'm
glad we can well the program Launches on
November 1st remember you can also call
Nevada 2-1-1 and they can help guide you
along the proper path because remember
every case is very different check out
8newsnow.com for more information